so we're continuing our conversations
with a number of different republicans
running in the 2022 midterm elections
today we're going to be speaking with
john gibbs john gibbs is a
trump-endorsed republican the former
assistant secretary for community
planning and development at hud in the
trump administration and is running in
michigan's third congressional district
the incumbent in that race is peter
meyer uh it's great to have you on john
i really appreciate your time thanks for
having me on david i really appreciate
it so let's start with something really
easy just to to to kind of get started
um
donald trump took a a a bit of issue
with your opponent's last name having a
silent j in it he seemed not to like
that at a recent rally you take no issue
with the spelling of your opponent's
name right
well i think the difference is i'm from
michigan and so we grew up seeing the
supermarket chain and whatnot so we're
really used to it but i can see how
someone who's not from here like
president trump would not be familiar
with that spelling or how i pronounce it
so you know that's how i look at it
beautiful okay so um
i want to start with
what is leading you to run most people
who choose to run say well to some
degree i mean people in media and people
in politics in a sense there's a
narcissistic element right like if
you're in media and you want to talk you
have to on some level think what i'm
saying is at least as interesting as
what anybody else is going to have to
say and if you're going to run for for
office to some degree you believe you
can do a better job than the person
that's there so tell me about that what
problems do you see that you think you
can fix
um well i mean the list goes on and on
but we have inflation which is causing
gas prices to you know skyrocket through
the roof we have uh
empty shelves at stores and you have
high prices at grocery stores as well
for basic things like chicken or pork
chops whatever it might be this is
having a huge impact on the middle class
and working class folks especially the
poor minorities you really got to step
up and do something about this so um and
that's just domestically that doesn't
talk about afghanistan and the botched
patrol and ukraine and what's going on
there so i think there's just a very
long list of issues that we need to
address and i think um very humbly based
on my experience in dc for four years in
our administration i got to learn the
machinery of how government works um i
was there for longer than my primary
opponent has been there so i've got more
experience than him in that um also i'm
a regular guy i'm not from uh you know a
super super loaded background
so i know what it's like to connect with
regular folks so i think i've got the
best of both worlds there but david i do
have a point i mean you have people who
are narcissistic and this profession
does attract those kind of people and i
myself after our administration was not
planning on going into politics i was in
fact planning on becoming a regular
person again uh you know maybe doing
some work for a think tank or something
and just uh you know getting out of the
spotlight for a bit uh but then some
friends you know for uh
said hey why don't you go back home to
michigan and uh you know take a run
against this peter meyer guy who voted
on page trump and uh it took me a while
i thought about it a lot i prayed about
it i made sure i had my ducks in a row
and they ended up diving in a head first
to do it but it's not really necessarily
about snaking i was kind of looking
forward to being a regular person again
so uh yeah i mean it it does really take
something to drop in here and do this
and it's very busy you know you're gonna
get attacked and there's long hours and
uh there's scrutiny and things but i do
really think it's worth it because
um you know we need the leadership in
there which is lacking right now so you
mentioned three issues there the first
one was was inflation and and price gas
prices and uh product product prices
that's uh that's something that's
happening globally right now there's a
number of issues there as one of 435
members of congress in the united states
what would you do to deal with the issue
of inflation which is a global one
well it's a global issue to some degree
but a lot of this money that's been
printed and the spending that's
happening does have global impact
because the investors take that money
and they invest it all around the world
so i do think um the europeans certainly
have their share of guilt in this for
doing some of the same stuff we're doing
but i think when you look at the kind of
spending and the kind of money printing
that's happening you're getting what's
called the cantillon effect which is
where all this money goes in to the
economy in an efficient way and ends up
driving up prices
in a way that is harmful to regular
folks so we do have to look at the money
printing uh and the spending uh which
are two of the critical uh points behind
this and david you have a very good
point if i were to win god willing i'm
one of 435. so i need to form coalitions
i need to have people that are on my
side i need to have the maturity to
understand that everybody that we're in
coalition with won't agree on every
issue but john i hate to interrupt but i
really like that i love talking about
policy and we were i want to stay on
that instead of the coalition
you're talking about money printing now
joe biden's administration did pass this
infrastructure package and that includes
government spending and we could debate
whether it's the type of spending that
you like or that you don't like but the
deficit declined during joe biden's
first year compared to donald trump's
last year in other words spending in
total the the rate at which we overspent
went down in the first year of joe
biden's presidency would you would you
agree with those numbers from the
congressional budget office which is
nonpartisan not the debt now remember i
know you know the difference you're a
harvard guy
the deficit went down in joe biden's
first year do you agree with those
numbers or you dispute them i'll need to
check that because i've actually heard
differing views on that so i'd want to
go back and look out numbers and see if
there's any fuzzy math going on there
as a general rule do you dispute numbers
from the congressional budget office or
is that a fair source in your mind
um i think it's not so much fair or not
it's a matter of there are many ways to
uh to look at these numbers there are
different ways of calculating deficit in
terms of what you include what don't you
include does it come off the budget this
year or next year or the year after so i
think there's lots of different ways to
slice the pizza here and i need to look
at the way they're doing that to make a
determination on that would you agree
that at least the congressional budget
office is doing it the same way every
year is that at least fair they are
consistent in how they measure the
deficit
i'd have to take a look at that again
and go back about their methodology to
see what's the case there but uh so let
me ask you this then if you're not sure
whether we can trust the numbers of the
congressional budget office what numbers
do you have as a basis to say that the
spending is out of control
oh we can easily look at the amount of
money the government's spending that's a
much simpler uh calculation there we can
easily look at inflation uh cpi and
whatnot uh those are pretty standard in
the way they're calculated so
we have a pretty good sense of what
those numbers but i think so let's see
but the the problem is you blamed the
spending on the inflation so like for
example in this conversation i'm
agreeing with you inflation has been
high we're 100 on the state there's no
dispute about those numbers
you made the assertion that you believe
the inflation to some degree is because
the spending is out of control i said
typically we look at the congressional
budget office for that and they found
that the deficit was down in joe biden's
first year of the presidency you said
you're not sure if you trust those
numbers and when i asked you well how do
you know spending is up you said well
because i looked at the inflation
numbers but your first claim was the
inflation numbers you believe are
because spending was up but now you're
saying the inflation numbers are the
spending numbers that doesn't make sense
does it it doesn't make sense as high
gas prices that regular people cannot
afford well it doesn't make sense is
that black pastures come to me saying
people in our congregation cannot afford
a drive to work because gas prices are
too high what doesn't make sense is that
the price of a pack of chicken or beef
or whatever you're buying at the grocery
store is twice as high that certainly
doesn't make sense and so that's the
problem we're going to solve right we
agree gas prices are high but you made
the assertion that it's because of biden
spending whereas gas prices are up
globally and what i'm trying to do is to
is to make that connection but maybe
maybe we're just not not going to be
able to do that let me ask you a
different question do you agree that
since the peak about two months ago
gas prices are now down about 20 percent
do you dispute those numbers
um what i do know is that gas prices are
still far too high one of the reasons
for that is for example shutting down
the keystone xl pipeline and totally
gutting all efforts to have american
energy independence uh so we've got to
go back and reverse those policies so
that we can be producing more of our own
uh supply which will bring prices down
okay but so let's so three different
things there you didn't answer my
question and you also made two claims
that were wrong so i'm gonna tr i'm
gonna do my best to keep keep up here so
do you agree gas prices are down about
20 from their peak two months ago
um what i agree on is that gas prices
are slightly higher than they were uh
when joe biden came into office and we
got to fix this problem and bring it
back down
do you dispute that the gas prices are
down 20 percent
um what i dispute is that uh gas prices
are good they're not good they're still
too high okay that's fair let's so
is 5 10 15 20. whatever one might be is
still too high that's the point fair so
now see john you they're not really care
if it's down 20 over the past couple of
months whatever but what i do care about
is way higher than it needs to be so you
made an assertion and i agree see i mean
i can very simply agree with you you're
right they're still too high so you have
see how i'm very simply agreeing with
you
are you disputing just that they've come
down 20 or do or do you agree that they
have
um i try to spend time on the relevant
questions when i look at my policy and
the relevant issue here is we got to
bring the gas prices down how do you
know they have to come down more if you
won't even concede they're down 20 how
do you even know what they are
i know they're way higher than they were
when biden got in there we got to fix
that problem okay so
it's it's not sounding like you're
willing to even in good faith concede
they're down 20 can you tell me why
um i can tell you that i care about hot
gas prices because it affects everybody
especially those who are important
working class in the middle class as
well right i agree with you you're down
i agree with you but do you seem to be
unable to agree with me on just basic
facts it's weird let's move on to the
next thing you said which was keystone
xl is responsible for not having
keystone xl i want to make sure i know
what you're saying john
not having keystone xl is responsible
for gas prices being high is that an
accurate assessment of what you said two
minutes ago i'm certainly part of the
picture okay we do have to increase
domestic production that's the overall
point did you know that keystone xl
would not increase domestic production
because it's merely a transport method
from canada that's right yes okay stuff
coming from canada as well okay i think
they get more supply in here so
if the keystone xl pipeline phase four
wouldn't increase production and you
just said what we need to do is increase
production how could it be responsible
for gas prices being high we've got to
do both obviously we've got to open up
that pipeline and also get more domestic
production
but you first said the pipeline not
being open is responsible for high
prices what i'm saying is since it
wouldn't lead to any more production how
is it affecting the prices
because we need to have more coming in
for here from everywhere whether that's
domestic production whether it's in
canada
but it wouldn't change how much is
coming in it would only change how it's
getting here
yeah and we need to have more ways of
getting it here obviously because that
will uh increase supply along with
increasing domestic production as well
but why would bringing it by pipeline
instead of truck lower the price
because it's more efficient
i've never read that before where are
you getting that
um from people that know about this and
people that know that when you have that
pipeline open it's better uh for our for
increasing the supply um as well as
increasing our domestic production along
with that
okay do you have any citations on that
because i've never heard that
um what i do have a citation on is that
gas prices are too high
i agree
i agree
okay um
i'm finding myself at a bit of a log jam
because we seem to not even be able to
agree on the kind of basic facts let's
try a different topic altogether and see
if maybe we can make some headway
um who's the president of the united
states right now
joe biden is certainly the sitting
president but it looks like president
trump likely won the election um here's
a couple of factory david one uh
president trump got more votes the
second time they got the first time
there's no such thing in american
history of the president getting more
votes the second time and then losing
doesn't exist
the second thing we know that's a fact
is president trump won the bellwether
counties and when he went to bellwether
county you win the presidency with 100
predictability president trump won those
yet still lost both of those are
mathematically impossible so that seems
to indicate very strongly that there is
some uh irregularities in the election
results so
you know people are concerned about this
rightfully so and so we really got to
the bottom of it as well as increase our
election integrity going forward if we
don't have secure elections we don't
have fair elections you don't have a
democracy so this is a really big issue
we've got to address right well i agree
with your conclusion we have to have
secure elections you said that something
is an impossibility and and what you
said was an impossibility is if you get
more votes the second time than the
first
historically you win am i understanding
that that assessment
yes that's right okay um have you ever
seen things happen for the first time in
your life john
of course okay and so something happened
for the first time in november of 2020
is that fair to say we'll get to whether
it happened fairly don't let's not jump
ahead but arguably something happened
for the first time in november of 2020
which is a sitting president got more
votes and still lost fair it was the
first time that that happened
well there's different categories of
things happening for the first time okay
there's getting into a car accident for
the first time okay uh well guess what
other people get in the car accidents
all the time so we know that it's
something that happens
you're talking about getting more votes
the second time you got first time
that's something that never happens and
so that's a different category that's
something that is almost certainly
mathematically impossible okay same
category as other things that happened
for the first time so let me give you an
example of something else during the
trump presidency that happened for the
first time and then let's see if we can
agree and then extrapolate from that
the average approval rating for donald
trump during his four years
was the lowest of any president in the
modern era would would you agree with
that and this is no matter even if you
look at a right-leaning pollster like
rasmussen which had trump higher
still on average trump's approval was
the lowest of any president in the
modern era can we agree on that fact
i might double check that but let's
assume just for argument's sake
let's assume it's fair enough so my
suggestion to you as a thinking man
well-educated everything we're talking a
high level here
given that trump's polling
was the lowest of any president in the
modern era which had never it was
unprecedented low
isn't it also possible that you would
see an unprecedented result in the
election is that possible is it possible
theoretically
no it's not possible for a president to
get 20 more votes than they got the
first time than still lose you know but
you didn't you didn't answer the
question
got 3.5 million let's vote the second
time the first time he still won okay so
you're really looking at just pure
impossibilities here
i'm not so you're saying that
there's lots of things that happened for
the first time during the trump
presidency but this one thing trump
getting more votes and losing that one's
not possible
that's correct because like i said the
different categories of things that
happen for the first time wow yeah
there's some things happening for the
first time that are plausible there are
some that are not
why haven't any courts found any merit
to the 63 different 2020 election
related complaints that have been
brought to them many of them trump
appointed judges why why is it because
the democrats have their legal game
going in a really good way i must say um
even though what they're working for was
not good um they had people like mark
alias in charge of it and they did a
good job of it our side was slow to
react still to respond and did not take
this issue seriously not before the
election that's just a sad fact i wish
it weren't true so that's answer your
question there but if there were merit
wouldn't a trump appointed judge say
there's merit here let's proceed
well you know if you look at our side
leading up to the election when it comes
to election integrity yeah prepare well
enough uh that's just a sad fact of it
so how could you have been more prepared
there was an army of hundreds of lawyers
and trump said for six months it was
going to be rigged how could they how
could you have been what could have been
done to be more prepared
um a whole lot more you need to have
action at the state level you need to
have litigation they did
watching there was not nearly enough of
that going on either poll watchers need
that poll challenger signed up
look in virginia for example at governor
juncken's election yeah typically in an
election in virginia republicans have
coverage at 20 percent of the precincts
as poll watchers okay but when governor
younken won republicans had 90 coverage
at the precincts that's a concrete
example of something that the
republicans did that was smart and that
made an impact on the election and what
i'm saying and i'm suggesting here is
that we didn't have enough of that
leading up to the 2020 election which is
why you saw some of the results you did
and that carries over david as well to
the legal issues um where there is not
enough preparation very sadly so um yeah
i think uh we've got to bring our a game
next time why do you think that in
arizona the audit that was done extended
joe biden's lead
um i have to go look at that a lot of
these artists they simply recount the
existing ballots which is not what you
do you want to go through and do a more
thorough look uh to see which ones are
valid and which ones are not et cetera
but that being said i need to go back
and read the details that i've got to
find out
exactly what happened but um yeah i mean
we really
got to make sure we increase our
election integrity people are losing the
faith in the system there are people
saying they're not going to vote anymore
because of what happened so we really
have got to restore the public's
confidence in our election system you
know the polling shows that the american
people are actually very confident in
our election systems it's just some
trumpists that aren't but what indicator
are you seeing that at the national
level americans aren't confident because
i just looked at polling and americans
seem very confident
i looked at pulling that says opposite
something like over half of all people
believe that the 2020 election results
were not legitimate even that's not true
even among independents the number i
believe was over 50 percent no democrats
number was something like in 30 to 40
range so there's a very very significant
number of people that believe that
unfortunately there were real
irregularities in the 2020 election and
that's why we've got to restore the
public's confidence in the election
process i mean i think you know the
that's not true that that's what the
polling is in the immediate aftermath of
the election 57 percent of trump voters
believed that that number has since
declined dramatically and right now only
about 20 percent of overall americans
believe that but i think i have a
different question which is just because
of a lot of americans believe something
does that mean we change our laws for
that what's your philosophy on that
well you know i think you have a point
there david that we do what's right not
based on a popular opinion but this is
nation where a popular opinion does
happen to be right i thought there were
issues and so uh like i said the results
were mathematically impossible so we've
got to look at what happened we've also
got to make sure elections are secure
going forward you know it's weird
because everybody who is saying that
this was a mathematical impossibility so
i'm hearing you say it
i don't know if you're familiar who mike
lindell is he sells pillows on
television i don't know if you've heard
of him i've heard of him yes yeah he
says it's a mathematical impossibility
sometimes lawyers who have no training
in mathematics say it's a mathematical
impossibility but then you go to actual
statisticians and they say there's
nothing here that raises any red flags
whatsoever
do you think there's some reason why
it's
non-mathematicians that are convinced
about the mathematical impossibility i'm
trying to figure that out
um i would bet that if you ask
mathematicians you will find that they
will say these are highly irregular
numbers um especially the two cases i
cited you so i believe that there are
many who would admit that these numbers
are impossible
okay
um when it comes to
your platform if you were lucky enough
to win in 2022 and i know you've got to
run in a couple minutes so we'll kind of
end on this note
uh
what would be your goal with regard to
what is being threatened as an
impeachment of joe biden if republicans
take the house and you win
do you think that that's something that
the house of representatives should
prioritize the way congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene and lauren bobert
and others have said
the evidence of the evidence warrants it
absolutely if the evidence says
the policies of the biden administration
deliberately have hurt millions of
people um with recklessness and
carelessness um if we determine that
then yes it would be appropriate do you
have any specific policy right now that
you suspect might meet that threshold
i think one you've got to look at the
covert response uh there'd be an
investigation there uh so you've got to
look at the afghanistan withdrawal which
got americans killed
and there's also the possibility of
looking at ukraine as well and the
absolute
lack of leadership uh that's being shown
right now those are some possibilities
and as we dig into those if we find out
that there are high crimes and
misdemeanors and those need to be
pursued so you're open i know you're
saying you're not saying for sure but
you might
support impeaching joe biden
for his response to russia's invasion of
ukraine did i hear that correctly
um if there's evidence that american
weakness has led to deaths especially
with americans which is not as much an
issue in ukraine but more in afghanistan
as well as on the southern border
frankly the whole southern border
situation which is human trafficking um
uh is is absolutely outrageous so if we
investigate those and we find that there
are high crimes and misdemeanors and yes
you've got a you have a constitutional
obligation
so
so the four possible it's four possible
areas of biden impeachment it was
coveted afghanistan ukraine and the
border is that is it just those four are
there more perhaps there could be others
you know we'll take a look at it and see
and if we find that there are high
crimes misdemeanors then we will go to
the next step wow wow
uh john gibbs john gibbs is running as a
republican he's running to unseat
congressman peter meyer that's a silent
j as we we now all know
uh john i really appreciate your time
today it's quite an eye-opening uh
platform and i look forward to following
your campaign
thank you david i really appreciate it
thanks for having me on